julian faust karlovy geschmäcker ihren
weg in die zukunft kannten sie genau
doch corona hat alle ihre pläne zunichte
gemacht ich glaube ich habe ungefähr 40
bewerbungen geschrieben und bis heute
tatsächlich bei manchen bewerbung noch
gar keine antwort bekommen also jetzt
ungefähr ein halbes jahr später schaffen
sondern auch bei den ausbilder schein
gemacht wächst treffe mich haben das
studio schon renoviert und waren schon
alle vorbereitet und nur noch darauf
gewartet dass ich mit der schule fertig
dass ich dann ja anfangen dann war
nichts
man braucht keine piloten mehr über
viele jahre
es gibt keine zukunft für uns dass es
nicht hat
wir haben ja hier unseren praktikanten
den julian der wird wieder fotografieren
ich bin damit dabei und wird noch so ein
bisschen mit eingreifen wenn irgendwas
ist eigentlich sollte julian jetzt schon
auszubildender sein
alles schien perfekt der schulabschluss
die zusage des fotostudios dann kam
corona und die absage für die lehre
es war schockierend am anfang und ich
wollte auch erstmal nicht so wirklich
glauben also ich dachte ja das wird
schon noch gehen dieser pandemie all das
geht schon alles da noch irgendeinem
zeitpunkt da stimmen dann so ok nein
der 17-jährige schon immer ein
begeisterter und begabter fotograf mit
eigenem instagram account mit corona
sind in dem kleinen fotostudio in
olching bei münchen viele aufträge
weggebrochen firmen feiern abgesagt
keine shootings in kindergärten weniger
hochzeiten für einen lehrling reicht
jetzt der umsatz nicht mehr sagen es ist
eine große belastung wir möchten uns ja
auch ein bisschen weiter entwickeln
weiterentwickeln heißt ja auch wir
werden älter er ist der junge nachfolger
der uns auch vielleicht von der
kundschaft her jüngeres blut mit
reinbringen würde und auch neue ideen
und dass man einfach wieder da weiter
machen kann und das fällt natürlich
damit auch wenn er hier nicht anfangen
kann
julian macht jetzt erst einmal ein
bezahltes praktikum im februar aber ist
auch damit schluss was dann wird ist
ungewiss
arbeiter hat jetzt hier weiter macht das
praktikum aber was am ende dann
passieren weiß ich nicht da jeden tag
aufs neue einfach und hoffen dass es
irgendwann besser geht
[Musik]
lass uns da weil diesen webcast gesagt
wurde dass die eigene ausbildung für die
man schon so viel zeit kraft und auch
liebe investiert hat jetzt einfach auf
eis gelegt im komplett abgebrochen
werden soll das ist wirklich ein schlag
ins gesicht
die bewerbung bei der lufthansa war
aufwendig nur sehr wenige schaffen es
die zusage sagt er war einer der
glücklichsten tage seines lebens werde
ich mich zurück erinnere zu einem
ausbildungs start da wurde uns
regelmäßig gesagt dass wir zur besten
zeit anfangen die es überhaupt gibt es
gab noch nie eine bessere zeit pilot zu
werden
der bedarf ist riesig der bedarf konnte
nicht einmal gedeckt werden dies ist die
ganze zeit und dann ungefähr eineinhalb
jahre später kommt sowas so was das ist
die pandemie
ende september wird carlo und hunderten
anderen flugschülern mitgeteilt ihre
ausbildung bei der lufthansa wird
beendet die berufsaussichten für junge
piloten so heißt es seien nicht existent
im ersten moment ist man natürlich
wütend und irgendwann kommt dann die
frage was schief gelaufen ist was man
falsch gemacht hat man sucht erst mal
ein bisschen die schuld an sich ob man
hätte früher beginnen können mit der
ausbildung aber das ist ja in diesem
fall nicht abhängig von uns gewesen
schon vor wochen hatten sich andere
flugschüler in einem video an die
lufthansa geschäftsführung gewand der
tenor wir brennen für unseren beruf der
gedanke an eine mögliche schließung tut
mir unglaublich weh weil ich weiß wie
viel diese pilotenausbildung jedem
einzelnen von uns bedeutet jeder und
jedem von uns ist bewusst dass es für
eine lange zeit in der lufthansa-gruppe
kein bedarf für cockpitpersonal gehen
wird doch wenn der bedarf wieder da ist
werden wir da sein pilot hin zu mehr das
eine herzensangelegenheit sobald es
weitergeht es sind wir an bord der ms zu
gerne und wir hoffen und freuen uns auf
den tag
auch carlo hofft dass die lufthansa doch
noch einlenkt das ist nichts was man so
wegschmeißt und für mich gibt es auch
keinen anderen beruf der mich auch nur
annähernd zu erfüllen könnte
wenn es irgendwie möglich ist diesen
berufswunsch doch noch zu erfüllen dann
werden wir glaube ich alles dafür tun
und in der zeit bis sich da mehr getan
hat halten wir uns mit nebenjobs über
wasser und versuchen einfach finanziell
über die runden zu kommen in der
hoffnung dass es dann doch irgendwie
weitergeht und wir gebraucht werden auch
wie geschmäcker hatte sich ihre zukunft
ganz anders vorgestellt
im juli hat sie ihren bachelor in
hotelmanagement gemacht wollte danach
unbedingt anfangen zu arbeiten monate
später war dieser plan zerstört
also 90 prozent waren es wirklich sagen
dass dann gesagt wurde ja sie wissen ja
im moment können wir morgen keinen
einstellen wir können die situation auch
nicht einschätzen wir haben das werden
die stelle noch gepostet als als wir
noch konnten und jetzt das ist einfach
nicht mehr möglich
die schlechten berufsaussichten die
ungewissen perspektiven zehren an den
nerven der 23-jährigen weil man sich
auch irgendwie gedanken macht ob man
selber nicht genug ist ob es vielleicht
doch an einem lied also weil natürlich
sagen alles liegt an corona aber
irgendwie macht man sich ja trotzdem so
ein bisschen die gedanken dann kommen
einfach auch die selbstzweifel als hier
mit wiebke sprechen hat sie noch einen
nebenjob finanziert sich damit ihr
masterstudium ein studium das sie
eigentlich nie machen wollte schon
damals weiß sie der teil lockdown steht
kurz bevor und dann ist auch der
knallten job weg
da geht es natürlich schon um die
existenz also man muss natürlich schon
irgendwie schauen wie man sich das ganze
leben komplett leisten kann wie man
miete zahlt wie man die studiengebühren
zahlt alles ja so einen nebenjob kann
natürlich dann ziemlich wichtig sein
weil auch nicht jeder eltern hat die
einen unterstützen können
unsicherheit ängste und über allem die
frage wann wird sich die situation
bessern
im endeffekt kann mir auch keiner sagen
ob ich nach den anderthalb jahren master
dann einfach einen job finden oder ob
man dann wieder in der gleichen
situation ist julian carlo und wiebke
drei junge menschen denen corona ihre
pläne erst einmal zerstört hat und die
hoffen dass ihre zukunft einfach nur
später beginnt